that's what we come in at the first
example and then we started to apply
that to a few different questions okay
well how am I going to move to the next
plan assuming V is s0 we'll come back in
a second
fine X is a function of time so now we
are gonna deal with time right which is
why you've got this initial condition T
okay so what is X is a function of time
right we want to integrate me right
that's how we usually do it integrate
with respect to naught X my team okay
because that's what relates displacement
velocity so therefore I'm gonna have to
say what to be right would you take the
square root of both sides
ordinarily we'd have to say I'm gonna
have a plus or minus on this side okay
but they give us a condition now
sometimes it would be actually usually
it would simply be so neat they say look
assume these values for me there'll be
some kind of detail in the question like
the way that gravity is acting or how
someone is throwing a ball which will
tell you they has to be positive or it
has to be negative or something like
that in a particular domain so I'm going
to just take the negative value okay so
I'm gonna get minus the square root of 2
X cubed as okay as usual it's critically
important that you actually state the
reason why you're excluding it on side
right okay what am I gonna do with this
what can I do is it how much to do
okay so my relationship that the one
that I'm after right is a relating
displacement I didn't do way the time
okay
that's why I'm going to get an X as a
function of time in a second okay so I
know that velocity is displacement over
time so I've got this set bar and I'm
gonna break this apart it'll be a little
easier to work with X cubed take the
square root
so what index my off top three
see if we can make this mass right now
pause for a second integrating at this
point this is gonna be problematic okay
because what you've got over this side
that's okay that's the X have to
integrate that and I'm gonna to be with
respect to time
why well what you've got up this side is
not with respect to T right so whatever
I get after I integrate this just as it
is it's still gonna be in terms of X's
right so what can I do here now if you
remember and this was something we dealt
with in rates of change and also this
morning right that the whole idea behind
these derivatives and chain rule is that
you can just sort of mix and match throw
these around just like any other piece
of algebra right they do follow some
other weird rules but by and large you
can manipulate them you can multiply and
divide them just like anything else
right so therefore what I'm going to do
is take the reciprocal of both sides
okay so I've got DX on the team so I'm
gonna flip it upside down and call it DT
DX now you flip one side so you gotta
fit the other as well right so - four -
that's gonna become minus one on 32 that
Potts flipped this X to the power of
three or two because it's already in X
form right I could make it 1 over X and
after I'm - but we know how to deal with
indices which one of the things upside
down how am I gonna change the index
yeah just stopping by to sign on it
right change the sign cross the line so
it's like it's upside yeah
I'm gonna make that so okay now I wonder
how many of you can see how many you
know you're called to attorney you can
see where this is headed
okay remember I want exit function the
time I've got all the pieces here I've
got time I've got my exes
it's just not quite in the right spot
what should I do now remember these are
these differential operators stuff we
can move them wherever we like where
would be the best place for a DT and
anti X where should we put them okay now
I'd recommend that you've got X's over
here
so the DX probably belongs over with the
x's right so I'm gonna move I'm gonna
leave the DT there okay and I'm gonna
cut the DX over to the other side I just
want to next to the power DX okay here's
the fun part
okay I've got everything I need I'm not
X's on this side T's on that side I'm
just gonna integrate no more okay
integrate this side this side now the
cool thing about this though what just
makes it work is that since I'm
integrating I've got a differential
operator here and I'm integrating with
1gr
right your different share this side
with respect to T you differentiate this
side with respect to X okay
mr. DX first cuz I think we know how to
handle this don't worry too much about
the minus 1 over 2 it's just the
constant okay if you're gonna integrate
this X apart - no - what do you do with
it what's the first step okay I'm gonna
increase the power right you're
differentiating that you're doing it in
reverse
ok so since you normally bring the power
down I'm gonna bring up so X to the
power minus 1 over 2 I've increased it
by 1 okay but that's not all I have to
do in order integrate what else have I
got
I'm gonna have to divide by the power
that just went up there right which is
minus one over two okay as we've all cuz
that's a fraction but we'll deal with
that in a second
now I'm gonna have my minus 1 over 2
it's still there
hasn't disappeared okay and because it's
a indefinitely jewel I'm gonna need some
kind of constant here so I forgot to
call that c1 so I guess I'll call this
constant alright now I've integrated the
right-hand side but I haven't touched
the left-hand side now it looks weird I
admit but you guys totally know what to
do with this
that's right now in case you can't quite
see it yeah right
this is no behind this it's why I put
this suspiciously large gap there so
that I could for this emulator that's
that's a 1 honey they're mine
it's a constant okay so if it was say
like 3 D key you know you'd you read it
you get 3 T well it's one so you're just
gonna get one T okay now I know that's
an indefinite integral
so it should have a constant with it
right but a constant another constant
still constant so one's enough okay yeah
she's really cool mom is there right
I'll remember we're after X is a
function of T okay I've got T as a
function of X so all I really need to do
is just reach and make X the subject
okay so let's let's clean up this awful
mess yeah negative negative if they're
gonna cancel - he's gonna come up here
right I'm dividing by a fraction okay so
this two should really belong here two
divided by root 2 what's 2 divided by
root 2 it's just root 2 right so I think
you'll have to put this guy X the power
of minus 1/2 now the half makes it a
square root as well and the miner speeds
is on the bottom okay so you go
that's fine now at this point I could
continue rearranging and they exit the
subject but it might be useful for me to
actually find out what this constant is
first okay so how do I find it out what
am I going to use knitting area type
need to get rid of X right so that's
where this initial condition comes in
okay so I'm going to say therefore at
time 0 it's a bit of 10 side 0 I'm gonna
get group to verify the square root of 1
that's the point at which it isn't it
starts no square root 1 Steve so three
or two or one so d the closet is minus
root 2 happy with that okay this thing
is dying rapidly let's try and finish
off
so if D is negative return I'll bring
that back here time is through 2 or 3x
minus root 2 so now I just have to do a
little work to get expert partners right
so kick the roots to it over I'm gonna
get this actually I should have just
left it where it was t plus root 2 that
okay so this denominator here in that
you read I'm just going to swap them
around
so root X root that and now I just squit
ha all right now there were certain
tricky things in there so let me review
ok
after you've got you've done a simple
part okay which is workout V squared ok
in order to move further and say well
I'm gonna get the displacement I think
you've got it integrate so therefore you
you've got to do with V naught V squared
all right so that's why I wear this
condition campaigning but there
furthermore when you're moving forward
these steps here you have a flip-down
that's that's that's a tricky part
okay that's hard to remember and it's
also hard to execute properly ok there's
lots of little traps in here where the
numbers can just screw you over if we
get to flip something or you forget to
make something negative you have to be
very cautious there okay but after that
it's what it just punches out yeah let's
see oh you know everything about this
one okay
I really like it as a question because
there are three totally different valid
ways to answer it okay and I'm gonna
give you all three at the end but I want
you to try and think of how would you
explain every we just assumed it that B
must be negative okay what can you do
you say why and in fact you know like I
said before the question will often not
tell you assuming you have to work out
that is this and then use that as the
basis of your solution okay sorry
how what's your explanation all right
I'll give you maybe